let's get started
my name is Casper volunteer here
and I want to introduce you to
the speaker of incremental adaptation of
spark dusk in Ray
um so
yeah so if you if you wrote here this
morning with Lyft and have some
complaints
they're right here no I'm joking but um
yeah so here we have
um
a science science Tech lead of Lyft
Rider app
and as well Hong Wong who is a tech lead
of Lyft machine learning
yeah welcome and
let's get started
hi everyone can you hear me well
all right thanks uh yeah it's excited to
be here thank you all for coming and
today we're going to talk about how to
incrementally adopt a distributed uh
Computing framework like spark sparkdust
or Ray and our talk will have three
parts so I will walk through the first
two parts on why we want to do
incremental adoption and why there's
challenges and then and while walk us
through like how the open source Library
field can help with that
so
why do we want to do incremental
adoption for distributed computing
framework
for anyone working in the data industry
we know that the data today are growing
extremely fast and the algorithms are
becoming more and more complex so
sometimes we find that pandas our best
friend became a bottleneck of our work
especially on data workflows
so this is because sometimes simply
because the data is too large for pandas
to handle or the the algorithm is to
computationally expensive for pandas to
execute that takes sometimes takes an
hour or more
um yeah so as a result
more and more companies and
organizations today they are trying to
adopt distributed computing Frameworks
to to build a more scalable and flexible
development environment
and the question now becomes
how to migrate existing calls into this
distributed computing Frameworks right
because they have different syntax
well if you ask Chad GPT we can see that
there are several challenges to to to
adopt a distributed computing framework
um first of all it made the complexity
of setup and manages this distributed
computing environment May simply seem
daunting for new practitioners
and second
the old application changes on the
existing workload may need a resource
allocations
and
um last but most importantly it may seem
counter-intuitive but we will walk
through with real examples
um it's the more it's not the more we
spend into the migration the effort we
spend
the more performance again we got
so this all calls for the need of
incremental adoption of distributed
computing system and particularly
I'm sorry
okay
and particularly for the portion of
workloads that can truly benefit from
the additional resources so for example
uh for training multiple machine
learning models in parallel and for some
of the future Engineers that are super
expensive and of course the data
pre-processing and sampling step
and there are several critical benefits
from doing so
first of all it will reduce the OEM risk
and we will be more cost effective and
it also minimized adoption effort to
achieve the business objectives and also
we will be more flexible on the
technical decisions
all right so incremental adoption is
really great but what is preventing us
from doing so today
and we will see this from a real example
um so here we have a a data frame that
has unsorted columns and with a large
number of unique ID on the very right
and for each of the for each of the
unique ID we have multiple time series
we have 10 we have 10 Columns of times
3.
and there's uh it is very standard way
to find outliers for time series is to
con is to calculate the z-score of the
time series
so
assume we have this existing python
function that finds the routine and find
the z-score for each time series and now
all we want to do is we want to scale
this existing function out with spark as
an example
and when people are doing it there are
two very common false beliefs
first false belief is people think zero
right will work I can just do simple do
a drop in replacement and then I will
fully Leverage The distributed computing
system I don't need to rewrite my code
and uh the performance while I'm
linearly skilled up
and let's see why that is not true
so using the example function without
catching it at all we try to call Pi
spark pandas to execute and we can see
the code simply cannot compel and the
reason isn't the past part pandas does
not support for the sort interface
so then let's try to remove the sort
uh it still doesn't work this time is
because a pet spark pandas were called
us uh it does not it cannot find a
unique ID we set as an index which
pandas could
so it looks like drop-in replacement
cannot be a hundred percent consistent
with the original solution like pandas
and let's give it a last try
um since the pandas Group by part is too
complex for callers to handle let's try
to just move out from the original
function and we rewrite using colas
Group by
and this time the the drop-in
replacement finally works but remember
our goal is not to have it work but to
have decent performance improvements
right so
to test the performance we run this
function on different numbers of Time
series and we can see that the blue the
blue bars are pandas solution
performance
it
I would say sub Optimum and comparing to
We compare it with a alternative
solution in the red color here so with a
more appropriate implementation of the
method
and we can see the performance is 10
times faster so uh how well
show us the details for the for the
alternative solution in a second I will
keep it as question mark for now
so this is the first false belief that
we can do
zero f word and get the get good
performance
and the second belief a second false
belief on the other end is believing
that I didn't get a good performance
because I didn't rewrite enough amount
of code I can get the best performance
by rewriting all of my codes using a
native API
so is that true let's let's test it out
using the same example this time we we
write the entire D score python function
using spark SQL and now it has nothing
to do with python and to make sure we
are fully leveraging native spark this
time we also run the test on the photon
environment on databricks
and here is the result
so the the yellow bars are the native
spark SQL and photon
it is really
mind-blowing that this native Sparks
sequel Solution on photon is not even
better than the callus solution
and we can also see that from the 10
000 to 100
000 series the performance is
consistently worse and for the 1 million
series case it runs for over 10 minutes
so we simply stopped it
so while this indicates that the most
native solution is not necessarily the
best solution
so to summarize what we learned from the
above examples
there's no zero F4 migration
um to allow us to just uh
have the disability computing power but
we always need to rewrite a code to make
it work
and there's no the semantic consistency
that's not equivalent to the optimum
performance and lastly fully rewriting
the code doesn't guarantee the best
performance
so now we have seen the
importance and challenges of adopting a
distributed computing framework and next
and we'll walk us through how the open
source project field can help
encouraging
hello
thank you Gene hello everyone
um yeah so now I'm going to talk about
uh how few can help uh incremental
adoption of the distributed Frameworks
first of all let me quickly explain what
does fuke do so we know that
um python pandas now we have paulus Pi
Aero they are pretty popular right now
and they all work perfectly
on the local python environment and they
have their own interface they wrong very
well right
but but what if the data is too big or
the computer is too expensive and you
want to now you want to use a cluster to
distribute this workload
and we can consider smart task and Ray
yes we can but the problem is
the complexity will be very high
um so think about that pick each like
each one from left side each one from
the right hand side
the syntax to make them work together
will be totally different different and
see how many different combinations you
have so the ideal Fugue is to build an
abstraction layer
on top of spark dark skin Ray as well as
the local execution environment so that
if you just add a very thin wrapper of
your existing python pandas polished Pi
Arrow code and then you can use the
unified way to
interact
with different environment to operate on
different environments and we will
guarantee the optimal implementation of
the code as well as the consistent
Behavior cross different backhands
that's what field tries to do
okay so let's take a look at an example
so remember that in drinks example in
order to make Pi spark pandas work we
have to create this z-score PD function
which operate on one partition of data
and then we can use this uh dropping
replacement magic to to work to scale
this compute English spark cluster right
so alternatively if you want to use
Fugue to solve this problem it's not
really bad
so this is the Fugue solution
and it will generate the same result as
you can see in fuel you just import
transform from Fugue and then you just
do the first parameter is you can input
any data frame second is the method
which is z-score PD and then specify how
you partition the data specify what
parameters you want to use and as well
as output schema that's it and pay
attention to any data frame actually
that is a very special feature of Fugue
is that your execution how this executed
can depend on the type of your input
data frame if it is a pandas data frame
the execution is just open a single
thread it's easy for you to debug and
easy to for you to find the the stack
Trace without a lot of like noise from
spark right but if the any data frame is
a spark data frame and then the whole
execution will be on the corresponding
spark cluster distributedly and output
will be the native spark data frame so
using this syntax you don't lose
anything but now your logic the z-score
PD can operate on any data frame that
fuse supports Spark
a task data frame and as well as Ray
data set
so let's take a look look let's take a
further step so remember them this was
the original function right we had to
rewrite that function to the previous
function in order to make uh Pi spark
pen that's happy right but now the
question is can we even avoid the
rewrite can we directly distribute this
function on any distributed computing
cluster so actually using Fugue is
almost the same the only difference is
here the L goal now we change to course
what does this mean this means I only
need the distributed backhand to do
course partitioning for me meaning that
for each partitioning can contain
multiple uids by this data but for each
group of data it can only stay in one
partition with this type of like a
partitions back we're able to just use
the distributed backend to do cost
partitioning and then apply the z-score
PD GP on each of the partition
and as you can see in this way we
totally avoid rewrite no rewrite you
have your original logic work and now
just one single function and this also I
need to point out this is purely
additive so far we didn't change
anything on your existing code nothing
no change just it's purely additive so
now let's take a look at the performers
so Jing mentioned that the Red Bar was
like 10 times faster than the blue bar
the red bar is actually the cost
partitioning solution as you can see
that we did we didn't add like
additional complexity I mean it's not
dropping replacement of course there is
a base thing wrapper a little bit cold a
little bit more code but that code is
purely additive but as you can see we
get a huge performance Improvement
compared to the magical uh dropping
replacement
right
um Okay so
you have seen the uh the performance and
the Simplicity of this solution now
let's talk about what will be the
process for incremental adoption how can
we move one step in a workflow to spark
desk and array here is just
um
something that I suggest you don't have
to follow but I really feel this is the
practical way I follow I feel it is very
very powerful
so if let's say you want to scale out
the score PD right the first step is to
just create a small penis sample data
frame that is small enough and just use
transform to write lightly and in this
way you do not have you do not have you
do not need to have a distributed
backhand everything is just local okay
because fuel guarantees the consistency
so you know that if you change the
engine or change the input it will give
you consistent results and but in this
way you can quickly iterate right you
can iterate very quickly the small is
small data and it's local and then if
there is anything wrong just change and
then run again you get very quick
iteration without high cost after you
have high confidence this works the
Second Step would be just to convert
this smooth sample data frame to a spark
data frame
it's still small but the second step is
to test the distribution of logic
right you don't have heavy compute but
you know that you want to make sure that
this function will work on on a remote
on a worker node right this is also a
very important step and do things
iteratively the first step is to check
if the logic is correct the second is to
check if the distribution is okay and
the third step simple is just to replace
that sample DF with the full scale spark
DF that's it so with if you follow this
sequence you will find your iteration
species will become much much faster
because most of your time will just
spend on your local local machine and
just to iterate on the first step
uh similarly if you want to move this to
Ray it's also the same
um you just convert the PD sample DF to
raise sample data set is one function
call in Ray and then to test the
distribution array and after it's
working just use the full scale Ray data
set
similarly for for task I didn't list it
here but it's actually the same
so to summarize
yfu can help incremental adoption first
of all
the core Computing logic can remain
untouched you don't need to touch it the
change is purely additive you just add
one more function called that that's it
okay and because this is really additive
the migration is also reversible at
every step you add something you don't
like it remove it because your code
Computing logic is still the same
so the third is the existing unit an
integration test should still work just
remember the the transition if you
operate the if you just run the
transform appendix information still
give your panel State data frame as a
result so the existing tests should
still work
um and also the iteration will be a lot
faster because you move a lot of the
heavy steps just to your local
iterations
not the least
the migration itself is not to tie
yourself to another distributed backhand
a heavy dependency instead
you now you are creating something that
is scale agnostic and the platform
agnostic
and on the field level guarantee two
things one is the consistent Behavior
by switching different backhands
and the second is the um the best
possible implementation on each
distributed backhand to maximize the
utilization of the system
okay so I have been talking about the
python interface the python thing about
Fugue right we know that for future API
we can use Penance Palace spark.com Ray
as the back end interchangeably
actually figure is also very good on SQL
site we have we could integration with
Doug DB bigquery trino and we are
working on snowflake integration
um so now let's talk about incremental C
code development so here I want to have
a pause and I want to have a survey like
how many people here are also using also
SQL users users wow a lot a lot great
great awesome yeah so
um let's take a an example so this is
tpcds It's a pretty
um popular Benchmark uh query set and we
take number 788 it's a complex query
it's very long you don't really need to
read through this query but think about
that in your real work how many people
have ever written such kind of long SQL
using cte's statements with statements
right it's a lot of code right and you
know you know um so
let me just uh segregate this code and
you will see that it has four parts
in the with statement we have ABC3
subqueries and the D is the final query
that will consume a b and c
okay so this is the tag
now let's see why is SQL development is
so hard why developing such a bigquery
is so hard
okay the first question how do you
iterate on each individual step let's
see let's say you have already developed
Step A B and C now you want to iterate
on D what are you going to do like every
change for every change you make
you probably just rerun everything from
a b c and d and the current version of d
on the big data very big data right it
wastes a lot of time and even for a
small change you have to rerun
everything that iteration is too slow
right and the second thing I believe
there are spark SQL users here and I I
think you probably can you know more
about this pen but of course for
bigquery and for other SQL you also have
this problem is if the SQL is low let
this big query is slow like where where
is the problem
how can you find out that so notice that
spark SQL has very good optimization
logic very good very smart but the
problem is
the consequence is the execution plan
shouldn't be very different from your
logical plan and from your semantic
Expressions so in a lot of cases you
have spark UI you have the very nice
stack of spark UI but you still cannot
point out okay where exactly is the
problem it's stuck but what the hell is
that I don't know I know I still I still
don't know so it's very difficult for
such a complex query you know to debug
the the performance issue in such a
complex query
and the last but not the least how do
you test the SQL so I see a lot of SQL
users how many of you are really testing
your SQL using unit test integration
test
um and and in in production how many of
you erase your hand nobody
SQL is really difficult to test I know I
understand yeah this is the common pain
Point okay so so first of all let's see
how a few can help to break up this
large sequel
and you can see that for the for for the
um for this part
um this this is the first part what we
can do assuming that you are integrating
that on a jupyter notebook you can use
this FC code um you can use this as F
SQL magic and you can use spark as the
backhand uh assuming the original query
is running on spark if it is audio
quinary is uh running on bigquery you
can just change the spark to BQ will
also work and the important thing here
is what I do is I'm using fixed SQL so
what is physics is a superset of
standard SQL adding some necessary
syntax to make SQL more capable to
express your end-to-end work logic so we
add some we have some additional syntax
here is we say we want to we won't pull
the result
um one percent take one percent result
and then I want to yield that as a local
data frame that exists on my jupyter
notebook so after this execution
YouTuber notebook will have a variable
called WS that is a local data frame
that you can consume in the next step
okay so this is the sample a very small
portion of data to local for the next
iteration okay another way if you think
ah I don't want to sample down data and
I don't want to collect anything onto my
machine okay what you can do is you can
hear the file s and this your file so
will make this whole thing totally
distributed you distribute it around the
C call and then distributedly write the
result to a temporary file on the cloud
so that you have the CSS the reference
you can still consume it on your jupyter
notebook both steps what's the purpose
of the steps is to catch right if you
catch this step no matter how how long
it takes 10 minutes 20 minutes and in
your iteration or other parts you will
never need to rerun this you will never
need to rerun this so the iteration
becomes you know isolated
you don't have to you know every time
you don't have to start from the very
beginning right okay so now let's move
to the last step assuming that I mean we
choose the first which is we want to
sample down the data and just to catch
them as a like a sample local data frame
on Jupiter and in the end we want to
iterate on step d
this is how we do that as you can see
something to notice is now I'm not even
using spark now I'm using duckdb to
iterate on the last portion of this of
the of the SQL statement why because now
I have sswscs as the local data frame if
there are local data frame I just use
that DB as the local execution engine to
iterate on the SQL so that was
significantly
um speed up your iteration and as well
as the print statement and some other
syntax that can help you further improve
your iteration experience and speed
okay after
everything is working now I will just
combine everything together do I need to
put them back into which statement
actually no this is another feature of
uke in field you can link nearly combine
your statements using this simple
assignment syntax on the background I
can tell you on the back end it will
translate this to which statement to the
CTE statement but you don't have to care
and there is no performance penalty
during execution we focus on a better
semantic a syntax and we think city is
not is not good so we make this possible
so you can linearly combine your SQL
statement so in the real experience you
literally only need to like copy paste
the code from different cells saying to
one cell that will work you don't have
to add additional syntax to make it
works
okay so if we take a look at the whole
process we have ABCD right now what
Fugue helps is now you can individually
develop on each of the steps
we are totally isolated you iterate on
each of them and more importantly
because for EB and C you bring them to
Local then some part of the DAC the
development can be totally local you
don't even need a distributed system to
develop that expensive sequel
and after development you just change
the backend from dark DP to spark it
will workable
and the last thing I want to talk about
is testing SQL look at this Hive SQL all
right you will have 100 excuses that not
to test this this is a hive how can I do
unit test how can I do like integration
test let me show you how we can do unit
tests on this table
so this is how you do it
first of all
we mark this table with the Penance data
frame
run the SQL using FC code
and then we just change the backend to
duckdb now this part becomes totally
unit testable as long as you have the
input data frame they can also the
output of this will be also a penal
state from so you can you can assert an
output panel data frame so we turn this
into a unit testable
problem
okay so key takeaways
if we have this chart
and the y-axis is the business scan and
the axis is the adoption effort of a
distributed system
[Music]
think
actually it is a curve is a curve that
will go down in the end right so it
doesn't mean the more effort you have
you will have more business can no you
will not only have diminishing again you
will have reduced again
and if you just a blind delay start the
full adoption it's very likely you will
fall on the right hand side of the chart
where you reduce again you waste a lot
of resources time money right instead
what do we want to do is we want to
incrementally
adopt
the system them until you see the
diminishing return you can stop you
don't always have to find
optimal point
not necessary because you know I think
sometimes just keep it like in a
reasonable I mean keep your effort in a
reasonable size is also very important
so in this way actually you can you can
closely monitor like the the value of
your effort
and this is difficult I understand but I
think this is a half you can help you to
make this process easier and smoother
thank you
any questions yes
as a library developer can I take a
dependency on Fugue and have it so my
users can choose which backend to use
even if I don't have to test all the
different possible backgrounds yes yes
yes uh it is uh so it it requires a lot
of effort but I believe we have done a
great job on that yeah
still a question here
you still have a question
oh go ahead
yeah I'm I'm curious on the uh the SQL
workflow since we are switching the
check-ins to that duckdb
um
obviously SQL back-ends have slightly
different syntax sometimes I'm wondering
how you handle that yeah yeah
um so um
uh uh you can choose like what kind of
syntax so by default for view by default
you are always using spark syntax
and when you run as docdb we will
transpile this to duck DBC code and
wrong
yeah so you can also change the default
syntax to duckdb and then you just use
the most native.tp syntax
this is very cool thank you
um I'm curious about the first part what
you had the transform function sure
um in the types that you talked about
the input data frame could be any of the
supported platforms yeah but the
function that you had was written using
pandas no no not necessarily the pen so
here is another thing I I didn't sorry I
didn't have time to explain for the
function
that you can support as long as you have
the taipan notation we almost can't do
the auto conversion so what we have so
you know um you can change the pandas
pd.data frame to polish.day frame and
still keep the output as pandasa from
this dude from X so what we do is we can
recognize your typel notation and to do
the data conversion for you so when you
write this function when this function
is wrong on worker we get the data the
data is already converted to the thing
that you annotated on your on your
function okay so you will do the
partitioning and then we'll do the data
conversion the data conversion is
actually a big deal because you know you
have super Flex uh super super
flexibility so what what I commonly do
is for example the input is a list of
dict here give like a list of dict right
and the output can be a iterable pandas
data frame a pen uh EO or a list of less
data frame all things like that
um so you you have a lot of flexibility
so this is another design philosophy of
Fugue is we adapt to you instead of I
ask you to adapt to me you we have very
flexible interface we almost at a
certain period of time and we call it
interface list because we really want to
be very adaptive to your logic yeah
I'll just ask a quick follow-up on that
do you use Arrow under the hood or do
you actually try to use Arrow as much as
we can for example for a few the typing
system is all Arrow it's no penis yeah
any further questions
okay if not thanks to speed oh
okay it works okay I'm curious the
transform function does that transform
our in this case pandas code into Pi
spark code or no it's actually uh if you
if you are using pi spark yeah and if
the input is pandas data frame yeah we
will try to use pandas UDF apply Panda
applying
mapping manner supplying pandas
and so actually we we use those
functions as much as we can but if you
turn off Panda's UDF we will use map
partitions to do this kind of thing
yeah so in the back end we try to use
the the best available methods to to
process for example if your input is if
your input is Arrow
annual output and and if you don't do
group by and in the latest python 3.3 we
now have mapping Arrow so we if we
recognize your input is errored you're
actually use mapping Arrow to process
this function okay that's we always you
try to use the most uh most efficient
way to process your logic I guess I was
just worried that
because of this transform becomes an
abstraction if if the resulting code
thing either slow or doesn't work how do
you then debug
the transformed
the transpirations yeah yeah so as I
said you should iterate locally as much
as you can if there is any performance
issue I hope that you can clearly find
that out in your local system okay but
it's not guaranteed I mean in a
distributed system there can be 100
places to have problems like for example
you in like a machine learning code you
forget to set the thread to like a small
number and so you generate a lot
original intention those kind of things
can happen yeah so you still need the
certain experience for certain cases to
debug yeah we do not we cannot cover 100
case but we try to cover as much as we
can all right thanks you're welcome
okay
any more questions
if not we thank the speakers again thank
you very much thank you
thank you